الى اخر التطورات المتعلقه بحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا فقد قال الكرملين ان الغرب يواصل
استخدام الاوكرانيين كجنود رخيصين ولا
يخفي نيته القتال حتى اخر اوكراني حسب
تعبيره من جانبه قال الجيش الاوكراني انه
افشل محاولات للقوات الروسيه لاستعاده
مواقعها التي فقدتها على محور باخ موت
وتحديدا عند بلدتي هيرو هفك واندريس في
مقاطعه دونيتسك ونشر الجيش الاوكراني صورا
قال انها لمعارك استعاده السيطره على بلده
كليش فكا على محور باخم واضاف الجيش
الاوكراني انه خاض 7 اشتباكا مسلحا مع
القوات الروسيه في الساعات ال 24 الماضيه
على جبهات القتال كافه وان القوات الروسيه
شنت 60 غاره جويه ونفذت 47 هجوما بمقذوفات
صاروخيه كما اعلن الجيش الاوكراني اسقاط
24 طائره مسيره من اصل 29 اطلقها الروس
باتجاه الاراضي الا اوكرانيه الليله
الماضيه قال حكم مقاطعه كورسك الروسيه
رومان ستارف ويت ان امراه اصيبت بشظايا
جراء تعرض مدينه ريلك لقصف اوكراني بذخائر
عنقوديه واوضح ستارو فويت ان بعض المنازل
والمباني والسيارات تضررت في مناطق متفرقه
من المدينه وتم العثور على ذخائر غير
منفجره في موقع القصف ويعمل خبراء
المتفجرات حاليا في مكان الحادث من جانبه
ق مستشار رئيس دونيسك الروسيه بانجين ان
مجموعه من العسكريين الاوكرانيين يزيد
عددهم عن 15 شخصا استسلموا بالقرب من
دونيسك واوضح ججين انه بحسب احد قاده
العسكريين الماسورين فان سبب الاستسلام
الجماعي هو الخسائر الفادحه خلال
المحاولات المتكرره غير الناجحه لمهاجمه
المواقع الروسيه في اتجاه دونيتسك حسب
قوله